ARARENENA.A.
THTHERERE E WEWERERE F FANANSS E
OFOF B BALALLL A ARERENANA..
THTHISIS P P O ONN
ALALTITITUTUDEDE A ANDND D DENE.
MEME H HOWOW T THEHEYY N NEVEVE.
THTHISIS I ISS W WHAHATT T THEHE
BEBEENEN W WORORKIKINGNG F FORON
THTHEE P PARARADADEE R ROUOUTETN
PEPERSRSONON..
LOLOOKOK A ATT T THAHAT,T, O OU.
>>>> I I'L'LLL T TRYRY T TOO I .
2323 Y YEAEARSRS O OLDLD,, A A Y
DEDEFEFENSNSEMEMANAN, , AA N NOH
FIFIVIVINGNG T THEHE C CROROWDW.
>>>> A ANDND I I W WILILLLHAHAN.
>>>> S SEEEEMSMS L LOLOL..
GOGOD,D, T THAHATT L LOOOOKSKS .
YOYOUU A AVAVALALANCNCHEHE F FA,
BUBUT T MAMAN,N, E EVEVERYRY T N
TRTRULULY,Y, E EVEVERYRY T TEAET
WEWE A ACTCTUAUALLLLYY H HAVAVES
ININ T THEHE L LEAEAGUGUE.E.
>>>>
IMIMMOMORTRTALALITITY,Y, T THAH.
O ONENE E ELSLSEE
CACANN  BRBR